oh hi I'm Rohan as Lee said I'm an 11th
grader at lynbrook high school in San
Jose so I'm from the south today this is
I think this is my third talk i gave a
talk earlier this year at PyCon and then
i gave one at pi Gotham in July so this
is my third talk at PI D to SF are this
why oh sorry sorry it can you hear me in
the back okay great so just okay so
we'll just wait for the projector to get
set up like this ok all right ok looks
like ahh okay looks like already so I'm
Rohan I'm an 11th grader at lynbrook
high school and I really like
programming in Python because well I
started like like if you saw the keynote
I started because it was easy and I'm
staying because of the community so the
community has been really helpful and
I've gotten a lot of great suggestions
from people about improving my projects
and stuff so thank you for that so my
pride my talk is titled machine learning
versus the flu so this project is about
using machine learning to try and
predict on how influenza virus strains
will mutate in the coming years based on
how they've mutated in previous years
and this my talk will cover the process
that I went through to Duke to do this
project as well as the libraries and the
challenges that I faced getting there so
I've pretty much covered this I'm going
to be in 11th grade this fall I've been
programming for since 8th grade and I
like bio informatics machine learning
and data analytics so let's let's first
start out with the problem that I was
trying to solve and that is the
influenza so chances are you've probably
had the influenza in previous years and
we take a vaccine every year so we can
try and gain
unity from it but right now current
methods of creating vaccines for the flu
aren't the best because scientists just
vote on what anybody's and drug should
go into the vaccine and this practice
has been called questionable by the
National Institutes of Medicine which is
not that great if you don't want to fall
sick and sometimes the vaccines don't
work for every strain so if you remember
in 2009 there was a worldwide h1n1
pandemic and that year the flu vaccines
did not match what the flu strains look
like for that year so a lot of people
fell sick that year and it was the
largest global pandemic since the
nineteen eighteen Spanish flu towards
the end of World War one so it was
pretty big so my goal was to create a
more effective way to create vaccines
and by doing that I wanted to predict
how the flu itself would look like in
the coming years so that scientists
could analyze that and based on how that
what that flu strain would look like to
use that data and come up with a vaccine
for that since vaccines are just
weakened versions of the flu strains
themselves so to understand to
understand how to create vaccines for
the flu we have to look at how the flu
would infect a host cell so I'll just go
off the podium here so if we look at um
that the first picture the little yellow
little yellow blob with the purple dots
around it that's a virus and the big the
big orange blob is a cell so look at
those little purple dots around the
virus those are called surface proteins
and they regulate entry and exit of the
cell of the virus in and out of the cell
so in the first in the second picture
you have the virus entering the cell
because the surface proteins have bind
it to those receptors on the cell
membrane and the virus has injected its
viral DNA and RNA into the cell next in
picture 3 as the cell grows the virus's
genetic material as well as those
surface proteins also grow and as a cell
is about to die
those the viruses recombine and they
exit the cell and go on to effect and
they go on to affect more cells in your
body so what I decided to what I learned
from this was to target those little
purple dots so those surface proteins in
the flu they're called hemagglutinin and
neuraminidase but for simplicity sake
let's just let's just call them haan na
because biologists just really love
super long names so uh what I decided to
do was instead of trying it trying to
predict what the flus genetic material
would look like so instead of those
little red squiggly lines I would just
predict how the surface proteins
themselves would look like so if I could
possibly take those out or try and
predict what they would look like in the
coming years then scientists can create
weekend versions of the flu with those
same surface protein so H and na and
then you're the white blood cells in
your body would know what the viruses
surface proteins would look like and be
prepared for when the real flu attacks
so my so my overall approach for this
project was to obviously predict future
genetic sequences of the flu so that
scientist screen create vaccines for
that and by doing this out obviously
have to use machine learning and I also
looked at a phylogenetic phylogenetic
switch is the study of which is the
study of relationships between
individuals on a evolutionary tree so
just looking at the relationships
between grandparents parents and truck
and children like so so you've probably
seen one of these from your biology
class in high school so here we have a
toy evolutionary tree of the flu
obviously those sequences are not that
simple they're actually 1700 letters
long I've just shorten them down for two
for base pairs for simplicity's sake so
if we look so we have let's look at the
bottom part so we have hgf and E so H is
a great grandparent geez a grandparent F
is apparent ease a child so
or what I wanted my machine learning
algorithm to understand was how how G
has changed from H how f has changed
from G and how he has changed from F so
if you notice H has a genetic sequence
of AAA G has a genetic sequence of aat
aat f has a genetic sequence of a ag and
he has a genetic sequence of a AAC so I
wanted my machine learning algorithm to
look to learn how how they have changed
over the years and then predict based on
that information how the child e what
the child of the what the child of e
would look like so in this case you can
we can reasonably infer that it is most
likely that the fourth base pair or the
last base pair would change would
probably change for the child aviso
perhaps a AAA or AAT so this was this
was my setup the so my plan of attack to
do this project so first was to obtain
data from the IR DV or influenza
research database this is a database
funded by the National Institutes of
Health with a lot of useful data about
flu flu strains such as the flu strain
itself the organism ID as well as where
was found and the specifics of the
person it was found in like the age and
gender & next was to read in the genetic
sequence of haan na and entrain a
machine learning model based on the
evolutionary relationship so how the
grandparent and how the parent has
change from the grandparent and how the
child has changed from the parent so
using that data to predict on what the
child of the child would look like and
then I would evaluate at our I wasn't
sure yet about evaluate accuracy some
way or another but I quickly ran into
some problems because back this was this
was last year and I was still kind of a
newbie to this whole machine learning in
Python thing so i thought i would have
to write my own machine learning
algorithm myself so i wasn't sure how
accurate that would be because I had
never
one before I also wasn't sure what kind
of machine learning algorithm to use
because I I was inundated with all this
information neural networks decision
trees what does that even mean I wasn't
sure how to measure accuracy and how to
read in a FASTA file which is which was
the file format that those genetic
sequences of a che and na were in so I
wasn't sure how to read those in so this
is where my first library helped me so
this is called biopython so biopython is
just a python library dealing with
everything but anything with biological
data so it helps with so by Python
specifically helped me with reading in
that fasta file because do it there's a
little module in biopython called seek
iose qio which is used for input and
output with specific biological data
because I quickly found that fastest
anta only it wasn't the only file format
that i use i also used i used fast as I
use GenBank which is another generous
sequence genetic which is another file
format for holding genetic sequences as
well as uniprot data so by a python help
me with all of those things so once I
got past that initial hurdle I had to
get to the flu prediction algorithm
itself so the good stuff were actually
predicted what next year's or next flu
seasons flu strain would come from would
be so I did some background research and
I decided that a decision tree based
algorithm so like a gradient boosting
algorithm or decision tree or random
force algorithm would be the best fit
because a phylogenetic tree is similar
to a decision tree as you saw earlier
those the phylogenetic tree has branches
where the child or brother branch off
from the main from the main tree and a
decision tree similarly has nose were
asking certain questions with branching
off based on the different answers but
so I went on to write a simple decision
tree classifier because I also in part
chose decision trees because it would be
easy for me to debug because I wasn't
because I I thought I had not learned
calculus and I don't think I could have
done a neural network
so I there are a lot of problems so
first off it was only classification
algorithm and I would have I would have
preferred a regression algorithm and it
often under fit my data so the my
algorithm was too simple for the really
complex flu data so it had really bad
prediction accuracy and it under fit my
data so this is where scikit-learn
helped me so I learned about
scikit-learn while I was doing this
project and you've probably heard of
scikit-learn the Python machine learning
library so this helped me in two ways
because first of all I was on I was on a
bit of a deadline because I want I
wanted to submit this for a science fair
and writing that whole decision tree
algorithm took a lot of time so say I
wanted say i wrote my decision tree
algorithm and I decided maybe this
wasn't the best and i wanted to write
some other sort of machine learning
algorithm that would also take some more
time away from my project which i could
be doing more background data about the
biology side of this but instead if I
could use scikit-learn instead and if I
could quickly not only where the model
is good they I could also quickly swap
out one for another so maybe if I didn't
like X model then I could try this
another model y and import it and it's
really it would be really easy for me to
just try out all these different models
and see which one was the best so this
is my updated set up with with all the
with all the Python libraries as well as
my background research so the first step
stay the same I would still obtain data
from the ird be I would the second step
I change because of by Python so I would
read in the genetic sequence of the flu
using biopython and I had to add a third
step which is encoding the data so
scikit-learn only takes numerical input
so I had to change the biological data
which is in combinations of a's T's GS
and C's into number into numeric into
numerical data and then our training
machine learning model on the
parent-child relationships are between
flu strains and then out evaluate the
accuracy using cross-validation & R
squared score so this is just a whole
overview of my algorithm in a picture
that I drew so I would create a
phylogeny tree encode the data give the
data to my machine learning model
predict sequences test the accuracy and
then add more data and see how if my
accuracy got any better so this was how
easy it was to read in a faster file
with biopython so previously I was
reading it in as a normal txt which
wasn't which was a real pain to try and
understand where the flu strain itself
was so right here is a is a FASTA file
containing 100h a strains so just using
one line I can put them all in a list
for the psychic learn for psychic learn
to predict on and so this was my
encoding method which so where I turned
all the like where I turned all the
letters of HTS Jesus sees into numbers
so I correspondent 1 to a 2 2 T 3 2 g +
4 to see so I so I first changed all the
letters to numbers and then I broke up
the entire genetic sequence into chunks
of 15 so in touch into chunks of 15 and
I put those all in one big list so each
list would have a each list would have
every element in the list would have a
number with 15 digits and there will be
two there would be roughly 80 80
elements in each lists so and so roughly
seventeen hundred numbers long would be
the entire list with every element so
this was my decision tree algorithm
before scikit-learn and this is my
decision tree algorithm after
scikit-learn so I did I didn't expect
you guys to read this so this was how
easy it was to read in to use a psychic
learn random forest algorithm which I
ended up using later I in the in that
first block of three lines I am reading
in i'm importing the library and then in
the last three lines I'm computing the
cross validation accuracy so this is how
cross validation I on eighty percent of
the data I trained and then on the
remaining twenty percent I did the
prediction and I evaluated the accuracy
and i also used r squared score to
evaluate how accurate my algorithm was
um while biopython and socket learn were
really great there were some drawbacks
because in my previous algorithm I was
using the grandparent parent-child
relationship so three generations of flu
data would be in my would be in would be
the training data for my machine
learning algorithms redic done but what
scikit-learn I could only go two
generations from parent to child so I
wish I could have added that extra
generation which have probably boosted
my accuracy a bit also I scikit-learn
couldn't take any letters or characters
and also couldn't hold that many
significant digits so let's move on to
my results so I trained on to flu
subtypes h1n1 and h3n2 so this is h1n1 a
cross-validation scores just little bit
of background h1n one or more commonly
known as the swine flu this was again
this was the one which caused the big
2009 pandemic and as you'll see these
scores were generally a bit lower than
h3n2 because h1n1 although does not
infect humans as much as h three and two
it's much more violent or dangerous
because it mutates a lot faster so at
the bottom are my three algorithms which
i use decision trees random force and
extra trees this is my cross validation
scores for h3n2 which is HT three and
two more commonly affects humans but
it's not as dangerous because it doesn't
mutate as rapidly as h1n1 so these are
the r-squared scores for h1n1 as well as
the r-squared scores for h3n2 so as you
can
as you can see a random force is
performing the best in pretty much all
the metrics in both of the flu subtypes
and I'll explain why in a bit so these
were these are all the scores and these
this is my comparison to other studies
so the to a bar the bar graphs you see
on the left on your left those are two
European studies so the one on the very
left is a German and the one in the
middle i believe is from spain so these
are both formula based approaches so
they just came up with the formula and
then based on that they were predicting
the flu sequences and my algorithm is on
the very right where I'm using machine
learning and as you can see the results
the results look very promising although
those were a formula based approaches so
yeah so so now let's move on to why I
think a random forest perform the best
so it helps with a little bit of
background on the different cut the two
types of flu mutations so you have
antigenic drift and antigenic shift so
uh the the main difference is that drift
changes are the smaller changes and the
shift changes are the really big changes
so if we look on the leftmost side we
have a flush of flu mutation so again
those little purple dots those are the
surface proteins so H a and na so these
drift changes happen quite often there
are smaller changes so less replication
errors and less mutations and these are
these are the more common types and flu
mutation so as you can see those surface
proteins they've just altered a little
bit from one generation to the next
generation whereas if you look at
antigenic shift on your right side you
see a lot of different flu strains have
combined to create one
one super super dangerous flu strain so
just as an example let's say the one
with the orange dots that flu tends to
infect people in tropical climates the
purple one affects people in temperate
climates and the green one affects
people in in a cooler or colder climates
so you see all those have combined their
surface proteins into one new flu strain
so that that new flu strain can can
infect a people in any climate us making
it wait so making it really easy to
enter the host cell no matter what type
of weather that I live in so this flu
strain can this this type of mutation
can be especially dangerous although it
does not happen as much so an ideal
algorithm would probably put those drift
mutations at a higher priority because
they happen more often whereas those
shift changes should be less of a
priority but still taken into account
because they can cause a they can they
can cause massive outbreaks like in 2009
so I think random forests performed the
best was because it created on an
ensemble of trees which lowered the
variance which gave less important to
the less importance to the shift changes
so what I think decision trees was doing
was it can it can tend to create over
complex trees which over fit the data so
it was giving too much importance to
those shift changes which was not good
as they do not happen that much and can
over generalize the data so random
forest with its random splits and and
generally weaker trees was able to pick
up those was able to give less
importance to those shift changes
because it because the real strength and
random forest is averaging averaging out
all the trees outcomes together which
generally creates for a stronger
stronger model and I think extra trees
gave to little importance
to the shift changes because they are
still to be taken into account but I
think extra trees did not give any any
importance to those shift changes at all
so in some I wanted to create a better
mechanism to create influenza vaccines
and I used biopython and scikit-learn to
simplify my data analyses and also help
me improve my accuracy and the results
look very encouraging and I am
continuing this work with with the
reason with researchers on the East
Coast and I and I'm now I'll take any
questions as well as suggestions because
I'm obviously not I'm still I'm still
new to this whole a Python machine
learning so any input that you have is
greatly appreciated and all and you can
see this project at this link so thank
you very much yeah
Oh x and y so X would be the parent flu
strain and why would be the child flu
strain yeah yeah
okay okay okay thanks yeah
yeah the haan na those are proteins
themselves they're not jeans yeah oh
yeah like I was a concert wow that's
that's one thing I'm trying to do is
instead of splitting it by 15 just split
it into threes and said is that what
you're saying like that yeah okay yeah
I'll I think I'll do that so instead of
splitting it into 15 I just wanted 15
because that was the most significant
digits that a Python float could hold so
I just went with that earlier but I
think I all starts playing it into group
like Three's which code like those
specific codons for those specific amino
acids yeah
yeah yeah okay
yeah I'm over that's what I'm working on
right now is trying integrating gradient
boosting like I've tried XG boost as
well as psychic scikit-learn gradient
boosting so I'm working on that like
right now because this was during school
this is during the school year so I
brought I didn't have much time so I've
been working on that during the summer
like right now which one ok ok thanks
yeah wait are you looking at these two
studies oh um well with the yeah i think
they are starting to move towards
machine learning like with the
researchers that i'm contacting on the
east coast they haven't fully caught up
with the machine learning strategies yet
so i'm trying to work with him to
somehow incorporate some point and then
based like right now it's it's a on 90
roughly 85 90 something percent so those
right now those other formula based
approaches they're also getting like as
you can see the one the one to the far
left it goes all the way up to 93 for
h3n2 so what i was thinking of doing was
keep like use those formula based
approaches and then for those for that
extra seven percent to get to a hundred
percent maybe use machine learning for
that instead of using machine learning
from the base and then going as far as i
can using the formula based approaches
and then on top of that using that
existing framework and then building
machine learning on top of that
you